hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to super people puncher now
I know what you're thinking that's not
what you think it is then that is a fist
as far as I know not on represent sure
on that it could be could be literally
anything but I'm fairly certain that
it's not what you're thinking it is
[Music]
anyway so this game is about punching
people really hard like not quite Falcon
punch levels maybe I don't know it's
it's a game about punching people which
I'm assuming is gonna be good I don't
know what kind of life let alo oh I
didn't I didn't do nothing
Oh what am i doing am i a disembodied
arm or is that what everybody thinks it
is let me try that again
hey sir please calm down I'm allowed to
give you the Royal Treatment do you see
my fists hang on can you see my fists is
legendary
in both its power and charisma so when
you think about the fact that you're
gonna be punched by me and my fist now
that that also doesn't mean that you're
getting fisted that's not what this is
about when you get punched by me and my
fist which is attached to my arm which
either looks like an arm
and penis but all that aside you should
consider I didn't do that well
all right well okay ha
this might be the stupidest game I've
ever played
this might just be hey there are
achievements oh no it's it's the
scoreboard okay alright so to thousands
the one to beat huh oh I'll show you
oh well I'm not gonna show you this time
around let's like spank the monkey huh
right in the dick you like that you sit
down down I mean you're laying down but
you know you could sit set more be more
City the London is my city
England is my city [ __ ] I even got the
stupid wrong okay all right forget host
forget this part why do I forget it's
quite obviously gonna happen oh boy I
[Music]
didn't have enough follow-through I
didn't follow through on the wom pitch I
got a really wampum if you think you can
escape my flaming fist here it's
catching fire oh yeah you see that
you're scared now [ __ ] huh I always
forget this part why do I always oh I
can't do I can't do it ah why how did I
get hundred how did I get a hundred and
then suddenly can't get a hundred again
okay okay you oh you're gonna be got you
bout to be I always forget every time
every goddamn time I forget why do I
I don't know if the screaming out but it
made me feel better
alright I'm gonna I need to I need a
really Whangdoodle this thing cuz this
is a problem it's a conundrum oh yeah ah
that's what I call the good stuff
alright hey on I just okay let me just
wind it back no that am I gonna what is
it well okay it's working okay all right
here we go
you about to be
first [ __ ] you bout to be Const Const
okay well that was a big waste of nothin
I'll get you I forgot again but yeah oh
it's so hard
really you bout to you you heard of the
the the wangdu wall yeah I was me coming
for your crotch yeah two for flinching
huh ah why I just I wanna I don't have
enough desk space for this I gotta move
my keyboard hey I got a really everybody
hold on I got a really hang on um oh oh
I'm gonna get you oh you think you think
you're good too good to be God [ __ ] I
always for every goddamn time how do I
keep forgetting okay alright cuz the
most desk face you ever seen
why in the goddamn got what how this is
how are you never listen
hey please please just please I'm
begging you
can you just [ __ ] do it where did you
go Mouse okay alright alright
[Music]
that doesn't make any sense I just want
to punch him in the dick why do I get it
go off to punch him in the ding-dong
don't you please please hey okay there
is one way I can think to beat this this
if I get some sort of like auto clicker
oh I mean be horrible and cheating ah
I just wonder why are you not I'm really
trying it don't get I keep weighing
doodling me on the damn it okay I'm
gonna go or hang on I gotta go cheat no
stop
we intubated penis penis into penis look
at that penis
wow what a great penis that it popping
in and out of the menu that penis really
cool that penis I really like that Venus
that's a good penis or penis right there
that is good our one and two and look at
it go what a penis that is that's a
great penis
oh nice penis all right I'm out of here
click okay I just need a clicker that's
gonna click left and right maybe this is
gonna work last time I downloaded an
auto clicker was for when I played
cookie clicker back in 2013 all right
welcome back to the knot thing that that
thing on the duct tape
welcome back I've got my cheat code and
I am ready I don't know if it is
actually gonna work oh oh whoa
clear Oh
okay it works okay that works
all right here we go I'm ready are you
ready cuz I'm ready all right here we go
maybe I should just why is it can one of
my let me just do f8 all right here we
go all right
click-clack yeah go go go go come on I
could I can click that fat off stupid
second you don't do nothing all right
okay all right hang on
fix this [ __ ] I'm gonna fix you
I'm gonna fix you okay ah my visitors a
tester oh just a test is just a test
all right click clack clack that's no
better
that's nope it's not better
ha there we go
okay all right okay so that's getting
there so I just got a really Whangdoodle
this maybe if I had two auto clicker
programs one for left and one for right
both fighting at the same time for as
fast as they can go okay all right okay
all right okay okay all right I got one
of them so if I just and then I open up
this other one okay all right okay okay
I got this all right
so that that's one auto clicker program
right here it's gonna clicks per second
let's put you at a hundred fifty just
you know and this one will be right now
this one's gonna compete and do the left
click and then when I hit this one it'll
do the right click I just need to hit f8
f6
yep this is gonna work great okay here
we go all right you guys ready for this
all right here we go no testing needed
[Music]
so I might just am I just terrible is
that is that what it really is is that
what this amounts to okay all right yeah
there's a limit at oh wow wowie okay all
right that is not happy with me all
right you know what let's just bail on
those I think there's a limit what did I
do
so I just do what I got to do with brute
force not good with that Oh where's my
cheese oh I don't wanna
ah I can't I don't understand you I
don't I don't understand how does it
okay all right hang on let's get some
i'ma do a baseline test a zero okay all
right I just want to I want to really
I'm gonna go for one-inch punch style
okay ah I don't get you very much oh I
just wanna punch you real hard wallop
okay you know I don't get it I don't get
I can't figure you out
but maybe you can I'll leave this one up
to you guys because super people punch
or just don't want to don't want to work
for how do I get the goddamn main menu
so let me get to that sweet fisting myth
I was not trying to do anything well you
know there you have it that is super
people punchers so let me know what you
think of that down in the comments below
I'll put a link in the description as
well this game is free and apparently
it's anti cheat so you just got to do
what you got to do and Bob's your uncle
you'll have success I guess so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
[Music]